this lava is moving at 30 meters an hour
it's not fast but it's really hot over
1200 degrees celsius
and burning up everything that gets in
its way
thankfully everyone has so far managed
to escape it
when people fled their homes they didn't
just leave belongings eliza gonzalez was
told she couldn't take her dog luna when
she was evacuated
their reunion at this improvised animal
sanctuary is bittersweet
dogs aren't allowed where she's staying
so luna will have to be fostered
there are good people that offered their
houses for the dogs to stay in and be
calm
of the thousands evacuated it's still
only safe for 160 people to return home
scientists say the pressure inside the
volcano has decreased in the past 24
hours but that doesn't mean the
eruptions are about to stop when this
ends that's something the experts can't
predict
and with each day that passes people are
becoming more desperate
ernesto de pas is a banana farmer the
island depends on the crop for around
half of its economic output but the
volcanic dust is damaging the fruit's
skin
and the eruption has cut off the farm's
water supply
if it keeps going for a long time it
will cause a lot of damage if the banana
fields are not watered we will lose them
there will be many losses many losses
the airport is open again after closing
because of an ash cloud but no flights
are running yet the whole island just
wants to repair and return to normal but
when that will be
no one knows
becky kochel sky news la palma